this is what would happen if you stopped  sleeping for a month  your first 24 hours of no sleep would  make you feel happy and full of energy  seriously this is because sleeplessness  stimulates the mesolimbic pathway in  your brain and releases dopamine but  this happiness won't last long after  these 24 hours all your reactions would  slow down and you'd appear drunk  on day two your body would stop  metabolizing glucose leaving you with no  energy and on day three you'd start  experiencing hallucinations  also at this time your body would start  breaking down your own muscles  and if you manage to stay up for two  weeks your immune system would be so  weak you could die from the common flu  and any time past that it's a guarantee  that you'd die from a heart attack so  please get off tick-tock and go to bed  because